It's true what they say and I didn't believe it until it happened to me,...
...but money can't buy happiness.
He said, "No, but it can buy Prozac."
And he put me on antidepressants.
And the black cloud faded a little bit. But so did all the work.
Because I was just floating along, I couldn't care less if clients ever called.
And clients didn't call.
Because they could see I was no longer serving them, I was only serving myself.
So, they took their money and their projects to others who would serve them better.
Well, it didn't take long for business to drop like a rock.
My partner and I, Thom, we had to let all our employees go.
It was down to just the two of us, and we were about to go under.
And that was great.
Because with no employees, there was nobody for me to manage.
So, I went back to doing the projects I loved.
I had fun again. I worked harder. And to cut the long story short,...
...did all the things that took me back up to success.
But it wasn't a quick trip. It took seven years.
But in the end, business grew bigger than ever.
And when I went back to following these eight principles,...
...the black cloud over my head disappeared altogether.
And I woke up one day and I said, "I don't need Prozac anymore."
And I threw it away and haven't needed it since.
I learned that success isn't a one-way street.
It doesn't look like this. It really looks more like this.
It's a continuous journey. And if we want to avoid "success to failure syndrome",...
...we just keep following these eight principles.
Because that's not only how we achieve success,...
...it's how we sustain it.
So, here's to your continued success. Thank you very much.